Well, good morning again church family. It's been a few weeks. I've missed
you, but it has been a sweet time
to watch how God continues his
work through the word through Phil and Allen. Did
they do a great job the last couple weeks thankful for them serving that
way.
We had a family Camp experience a couple
weeks ago up in Glorietta. And then last week I
was with our students as you can see all week. And so it was really fun to
see what God did through that. And this next
week is Kids Camp. I'm preaching Kids Camp. So it's his
Camp season for all of us. But today we're gonna continue our series through
Jesus parables in the Book of Luke where we're seeing
how God is separating things out and today we're going to
study one of the most well known Parables. It's typically called
the parable of the Prodigal Son.
As you're going to see though, the parable actually doesn't stand on
its own. There are others that surround it and fill in
some gaps even further.
We might not be understanding that Parable to its fullest
extent and so we need to really dig deep into
it to understand it.
Because when we take this whole section all of Luke 15 and it's
context there's main threads going throughout it.
You'll see it in a moment. But really there's a question God is
asking us asking them and asking us through the
whole thing.
That he is. Joyfully throwing a party are you going to come?
Like that's that's in essence what we're gonna see in Luke 15 a God's
throwing a party full of joy. Are you going to
come?
We'll see how that fills in a lot
of ways today in Luke chapter 15 that thread
of the party will go throughout Luke
15 take a copy of God's word turn there with me if you're not already there.
Luke 15 as you find it again as we've
done every Parable we need to know the context of what we're
studying here. And so we're gonna start by remembering the
context of why Jesus even says
this Parable in Luke 15
So Luke, 15 verses 1 through 3 to start with set in
the scene for what he says.
It says the tax collectors and sinners were all Drawing Near to
hear Jesus and the Pharisees and the scribes grumbled.
Saying this man receives Sinners and eats with
them.
So he told them this parable.
So that again is the entire context in
which Jesus then goes as we'll see next painted
the picture of this parable.
And so what's the context again? The context is that
the Lost were coming and the Pharisees were grumbling.
Pretty straightforward. You see it right there. The the Lost were
coming. Remember when Luke uses the terms tax collectors
and sinner. He's talking about the outcasts all
of those who the religious people avoided because of they are
they were sinful. I'm gonna avoid them. He says tax collectors
and sinners is a catch-all term.
So the loss the Sinners were coming to Jesus, but
the Pharisees were grumbling because of
that they avoided those people.
But Jesus was different, right?
Jesus didn't avoid them. He actually ate meals with them to show them
value.
And that made the Pharisees Furious.
I'm gonna Rabbi so-called rabba. How could he eat with those
kind of people?
And so Jesus told them this parable.
Now notice before we get into the parable verse 3.
There is a singular word there
right? It's the parable.
It seems like as we go through it, there might be even four parables
in this but I think it's it's all one Parable. Jesus
doesn't transition between the scenes very much. It
just kind of tells the parable.
It has different sections giving different angles on
what he's trying to teach us and so as we look through it, you're gonna see
what do we learn from this Parable? We saw the context now,
what do we learn from? What Jesus is trying
to teach them what he's trying to teach us? What do we learn here?
Well first we learn from his stories about
the sheep and the coin that's the first two scenes
kind of put together. Look at Verses 4 through
10.
He begins his parable.
Saying what man of you having a hundred sheep if he's lost one of
them does not leave the 99 in the Open Country go after the one
that is lost until he finds it.
And when he's found it, he lays on his shoulders rejoicing.
When he comes home, he calls together his friends his neighbors saying to them
Rejoice with me. I found my sheep. That was lost.
Just so I tell you there will be more joy in heaven over
one sinner who repents then over 99
righteous persons who need no repentance.
Or what woman having 10 silver coins? If she loses one coin
does not light a lamp sweep the house seek diligently until
she finds it.
And when she's found it, she calls together her friends and neighbors saying Rejoice
with me. I found the coin that I lost.
Just so I tell you there's joy before the angels of God over one
sinner who repents?
Similar scenes right now instead of trying to
pick apart every detail of these two similar stories. We need
to remember Jesus's Point here.
What's he trying to say? Because remember the religious leaders were
grumbling against him as we told them these words. What
was he trying to teach them?
Well first like we remember the sword method made a couple weeks ago. First question
we asked is was he trying to teach about God?
What does this teach us about God here?
Just these couples Verses first. The lesson we
learn about God is that he diligently seeks the Lost.
It's pretty clear, right? He's seeking the
Lost.
Which is in fact, if you remember the thesis of the entire Book of
Luke is Luke 19:10, Jesus himself saying this
is my purpose in coming Luke 19:10.
He says the son of man came to seek
and to save the Lost.
That's his whole point in coming which actually is
a fulfillment of Prophecy all the way back from Ezekiel 34
a few hundred years earlier.
Says I will seek the laws. This is God talking. I
will seek the lost. I will bring back the straight. I'll
bring bind up the injured. I will strengthen the
weak.
Jesus is simply fulfilling prophecy saying
I came for the Lost.
And that's what the parable shows right?
Obvious, it's not that complicated that God's heart is to
seek and save the Lost those far from God not those
who think I'm good with God.
Because that's what he means in verse 7 if you notice what he said he seems
to say that 99 people don't need repentance.
Now he's not saying that those people are perfect that they don't need
God in some way. They're gonna make it on their own. No, it's what
he said just a few chapters earlier back in Luke 5 a
similar situation. He's facing with these Pharisees.
They were grumbling at his disciples saying why do
you eat and drink with tax collectors and sinners almost the same thing?
Here's what Jesus said back then he said those who are well have
no need of a physician, but those who are sick.
I have not come to call the righteous but Sinners to
repentance.
Seems again confusing and Jesus saying you don't need
repentance. If you're perfect if you're good enough. No, he means that
he did not come for those who assume that they're
good enough.
For those who?
Who think I've got it all together. I'm okay. No,
he came for those who know that they are sick
spiritually.
Who know that they do need a savior? That's that's the idea
you go to the doctor because you know, you're sick.
I know I got a problem. Can you fix it?
physician he
Can't so that's God's heart for the Lost, aren't we? So thankful for that.
If we really knowledge and recognize our sin, we know
we have a physician a doctor to heal
us.
So we see God's heart here. But even further did you
notice as I was reading through Luke 15. Did you notice how many times the
word Joy showed up?
in seven verses right here shows up five times
It's the Greek word Cara which means gladness.
And it's used in Joy, but also in rejoicing those are very similar
words, but that Roots the same and and that word Cara means
both the happy gladness emotion
you feel on the inside when you're joyful.
But also the action externally you do when you're
joyful.
So with joy and rejoicing both inside you
saw that with the shepherd and the woman, right? They felt Joy, but
then what their friends too, they threw a big party together because
they were Overjoyed they found what was lost Jesus says
that's what's happening in heaven when a sinner
repents.
Like we don't think that way very often right that God is
throwing a party.
When someone turns and believes like this week, it can't God through
a couple parties in heaven because of what happened.
It's a picture of God that we're learning about him that he's full
of joy over the Lost being found.
So the first question is we learn things about God.
But the second question of the sword method is that we learn things about
us in response. And so
we learn things here in this section about us a couple brief things here.
Clearly first if we want to enter God's game if we want to get in
the party.
The way in is that we must repent of our
sin.
It's obvious. It's clear the way in to the
party is repentance.
He's talking about lost people here. And he says the way
they are found is through repentance.
It's like Isaiah 53 says that we are like
sheep each one of us have gone astray.
Turn to our own way.
And then it goes through and it talks about the suffering servant about Jesus a prophecy
of him in essence saying that because of jesus' Life
Death and Resurrection in our place.
When we turn from our sin and turn to him as our
savior, then we are saved.
We recognize we are sheep that have gone astray and
we need him we are found.
As we turn away and turn to him.
And so we we know we enter through repentance, but
also that should lead us to celebrate too, right?
Like this Kingdom has come.
And if we've been graciously included in the kingdom of God when
we don't deserve it, we're far from God. We're running away from him
and he's included us into it. Should that not bring joy?
Like should that not mean we celebrate like
heaven does in response to Salvation.
Just think about
when you hear of someone.
Turning from their sin and trusting in Christ. When you see someone baptized in
response to that when you hear someone's life change. Does
that stir your heart at all?
It should.
God's up there throwing a party.
It should stir us even deeper.
Do you rejoice over God's work in your life?
Do you see joy in response to what he
has done? I mean, this is Life Giving hope that's
one of our values that that should create an atmosphere of
Joy because of the Gospel.
Grace should saturate us because of
the Gospel change that we've been brought into
and that means we should then explode with
praise with worship with Declarations of
our faith. Right? Why should we be upset seemingly
about this?
Sad about our Salvation. This should lead to overwhelming
Joy celebration. Like what
Jesus says is happening in heaven.
Which should also then lead us to imitate God and go after the lost as well.
If this is God's heart.
To seek and save the Lost we should
join him in that effort.
Now their salvation is up to God. That's I can't save
them that's up to him. But he
has chosen to use us as partners in the process.
And so we get to go we get to share.
As an opportunity to participate in his mission. It
is a good grace.
That we get to go.
Now Jesus was not finished yet in Luke 15.
We've just seen seven verses.
And really all we've seen so far
has been setting us up for the next passage, which
is probably the most popular story Jesus ever told commonly again
known as the parable The Prodigal Son.
But here's what we need to be careful about whenever we
start titling things or even the headings in
your Bible that were not originally in the scripture. These
were added for clarity and to help us understand
things. But but anytime we add a title it starts
to direct our interpretation of it.
And so when we hear the parable of the Prodigal Son our first
thought goes to that. This is about the one
son.
But there's actually a Twist in this.
There's a Twist that will see when we read the whole
thing.
And we'll get to it in a little bit, but we can learn
first from the younger son. So don't think this isn't about the sun. It
is partially about the Sun but we need to learn from him. And
this is the part of this section here versus 11
through 24 about the younger son primarily.
So notice Jesus continues his parable.
And he said there was a man who had two sons.
And the younger of them said to his father father give me the share of properties coming
to me. Give me my inheritance basically.
And he divided his property between them the two sons.
Not many days later the younger son gathered all that he had
and took a journey into a far country and there he squandered
his property in Reckless living.
And when he had spent everything a severe famine arose in
that country, he began to be a need.
So he went and hired himself out to one of the citizens of
the country who sent him into his fields to feed pigs, and he
was longing to be fed with the PODS of the pigs ate and
no one gave him anything. You see just this continual degradation.
in his life
verse 17
but when he came to himself
He said how many of my father's hired servants have
more than enough bread.
But I perish here with hunger.
I'll arise and go to my father and I will say to him
father. I've sinned against heaven. And before you I am
no longer worthy to be called your son.
Treat me as one of your hired servants.
And he arose and came to his father.
But while he was still a long way off.
His father saw him and felt compassion and ran
and embraced him and kissed him and the
son said to him father. I've sinned against you
heaven. And before you I'm no longer worthy to be
called your son, but the father said to
his servants bring quickly the best robe put
it on him put a ring on his hand and shoes on his feet and bring the
fat and calf and kill it. Let us eat and celebrate for
my son was dead and is
alive again he was lost and is found and they
began to celebrate.
You see the similarities already right the first two sections. This
one looks very similar much more detailed. But you hear a lot
of the same thing something cherished was lost and then
it was found.
And again, we could get all hung up on the details how all this works out everything
like that, but don't miss what Jesus was trying to
teach in the context that he was talking.
Again, what was he teaching about god? Let's like that first. What was he
teaching about God through this account of the younger son. We've added
on what we've already learned. Now this
this sections pointing us to God as
our gracious and loving father.
That's the father. He's a picture of who God is
here. And what does he do first? He provides with abundance.
This good gracious father is a provider with
abundance, right? He says the young man
wakes up and he says
and everybody in my father's house has more
than enough.
And I'm sitting here trying to eat pig food. Like they
have more than enough. My father has everything that I
need.
Set not a picture of our heavenly father.
Who owns the cattle on a thousand hills who is Sovereign
over all creation? He is more than enough for you.
He will always give us what we need. Maybe not what we want, but what we need.
He's a good father.
He provides with abundance.
Yet this son.
for whatever reason
he looked at his dad and he said you're dead to
me.
Essentially, that's what he was doing when he was asking for his part
of the Heritage earlier, which would have been a third. The oldest son would've
got a double portion. So he would have got a third of the estate when his dad
died. He says give it to me now.
I don't care if you're alive or dead basically.
And so that that was disrespectful enough,
right?
But then even further this young man takes all that
he had probably sold it all got the money and then
went away and wasted it all.
an additional slap in his father's face
think how far this young man has gone.
But what happens?
When the sun turned to come back home.
Verse 20 shows us the father
responds with compassion.
again, this is teaching us about
Who our father is?
his heart
The Father Here responds with compassion that's a word
in the original language. That means empathy.
That he felt what his son was feeling took
it upon himself and notice
what he didn't do.
The sun comes up the path. He runs to him. The father didn't chastise the
son.
The father didn't jump his case for
wasting all that money.
He didn't jump all over him for for living in that sinful lifestyle
that he was doing. No. He looked at
his son. And he said this is my beloved child.
And he Embraces him and he kisses him but notice it wasn't just
that.
Right this this is a picture of the love God
has for his people that we go and make
a mess of Our Lives yet when we come home see what
happens. He Embraces. He kisses he redeems
back into the family, which is a word. That
means seat back at the table.
He puts the robe the ring the shoes which by
the way would have Illustrated. He's not a slave. He's not a Hired Hand
because they would have been Barefoot. He has shoes on which means you're a part
of the family son.
You took off you ran away you wasted it, but you're a
part of my family.
He embraced it all of that. You can think of the love
that son was feeling in that moment, but then not only that.
What do you do he threw a party?
Same as the shepherd same as
the woman he threw a party the Father Here celebrates
with life.
Both the emotion the joy that
he felt inside he expressed outwardly. Let's throw a party.
He's celebrated with life in that but also think about this
what he says in verse 24 this my son
was dead.
In essence was dead and is alive again this
father is throwing a resurrection
party.
That his son was effectively dead he'd gone
and now he is alive here in
the flesh. What Joy think of the joy they
had when Lazarus walked out of that tomb right think of the joy the disciples
had when Jesus was out of that tomb right? That's the same kind
of idea. He's like, my son is alive. I cherish
child is back.
That's what happens in heaven.
and I think think of it when
When a sinner repents he says when when a sinner
comes from Death To Life spiritually.
It's a resurrection party in heaven.
so we get this deeper and deeper heart picture of
who God is
We learn about him but that again teaches us about ourselves then
right?
We learn things about us from this same passage that
we see the grace of God. We see the love
of the father. But then what do we learn about us?
Well, we can easily forget our identity just as
much as the younger son.
We can forget our identity too, right you see this here with this
young man when he when he responds the way
he does when he comes to the end of himself in the far country. He
thought back and he remembered how his father would
always provide enough for him.
I was a son. I'm a son. Why would my father forsake me?
I I have
I have everything I need for my good father. Why would
I run away? Why would I not need but
But he also remembers how he was supposed to reflect his
father's values.
And he failed at that and so he forgot who
he was.
How often we do the same thing, right?
We forget that God's created us to be his image bearers.
To mirror him to the world. We forget that
he has created us to be an intimate relationship with
him that that's our primary sweet spot
of life is to be in relationship with God and
so we try to find our identity and everything else.
And sinful living in what people
think about us and we we try to find identity all over
those places and we forget what our father says
about us.
We end up in the far country looking for identity and it never comes
through we forget what our father says.
We've all been there.
but remember
there's good news here at the same time.
See when you see your past is too dirty.
Right. Now you might be feeling that that you have gone too
far that you're drifting away from the father and you're in that far
country and you have gone too far. You might feel that
right now hear me you can always return in humility.
That's the picture right the younger son. You can always return this
young man. He lost everything he hit rock bottom.
He had to feed pigs. Remember for the
Jews pigs were unclean
and he's not only feeding them kind of laying down
with him. He's one to eat what they're wanting to eat.
He is as far gone from his
identity as you can get.
But the text says he came to himself.
That's a phrase. That means he kind of woke up.
He he had a true picture of himself
a true picture of his situation.
Had experience like this a couple weeks ago when we were on our family Camp
trip. We went white water rafting.
And our guide his name was Drew and we're just talking you're on the boat for two
hours with them. You can talk about everything.
And through the course of the time we got to the kind of talk about his life and
he used almost that exact phrase.
As he was just feeling comfortable he opened up and talked about
how he came to the end of himself.
And just had to give up so he moved to the mountains didn't know where he's
going for. And so what it gave me the opportunity to do was
just talk about how I had to as well.
I had to come to myself and I had to run home to Jesus. I had
to come home. I had to see him as better. I had to
come home. I don't know if Drew trusted Christ or not. I don't know where
he is. I gave him my phone number. We'll see if he calls but let's see.
See what God is doing here.
He is getting us to the end of ourselves.
Just like this younger son. We have to get there, but think about what
the younger son woke up to.
He came to the end of himself, but what did he see? He felt unworthy.
He felt humiliated he assumed if I go home, I'm gonna
have to give up my status as a son. I wasted his money. I spit
in his face all of that.
And so he's on the way home. He's practicing this speech. You know,
he's got it in his head. Yeah before he can even get the
whole speech out. Did you see that?
He said a couple of the pieces but
then as soon as his father heard a repentant heart. He
said you're forgiven.
The son assumed I'm not going to be able to be a son
anymore and the father said come on in son.
Same thing God does with us friends. Listen, you are not too
far gone.
You have not sinned too much. It's not too late. You
can always return in humility God
your father is looking down that long road. He's watching
for you to come to the end of yourself and he's
wanting you to turn back to him for you
to humbly admit. You were wrong that you sinned against
him. Yes. He knows you did it. So admit it
and then he wants to say to you my arms are
open wide for you to return to me.
Come home.
Your father is joyfully throwing a party
are you going to come?
It's for Sinners Like You and Me.
Now we could stop there.
And be great.
like that's what a lot of sermons do at that point is
Is God welcomes and transforms Sinners? Let's
let's play Just As I Am, let's have a great time. Let's respond all
of that. Absolutely.
But do you remember?
how Jesus began this section in
verse 11
And he said there was a man who had two
sons.
See there's a second son in this Parable. And actually this
son is jesus' primary point.
Of this whole parable.
I know we identify with the younger son in many ways rightly, right?
We we need that picture and it's absolutely true.
But think again about the context.
These Pharisees were grumbling about Jesus
spending time with Sinners. And so he told
them this Parable with this last section as the
punch.
All of it's been preparing for this section dealing
with the older son.
Look at it in verses 25 through 32.
Now his older son was in the field.
And as he came and Drew near to the house, he heard music
and dancing. That was the party that the father was throwing for
the younger son verse 26. He called one of the servants and asked what
these things meant.
And he said to him. Your brother has come your father's
killed the fat and calf because he received him back safe
and sound.
But he was angry.
refused to go in
his father came out and treated him
pleaded with him.
But he answered his father look.
He goes here the sarcasm look these many years I've served
you.
I never disobeyed your command yet. You never gave me
a young goat that I might celebrate with my friends.
But when this son of yours not my
brother when this son of yours came who has
devoured your property with prostitutes, you killed the fat and calf
for him.
the father said to him
Son, you're always with me.
All that is mine is yours.
It was fitting right to celebrate and
be glad for you. This your brother.
Was dead and is alive.
He was lost.
his found
now you see the structure again is pretty similar. All four
of these scenes were highlighting the
celebration of finding what was lost life out
of death all of that.
But there's a huge difference, right?
The older son had a very different perspective on
this whole ordeal.
again, remember the context
Jesus is telling this sin.
You see where we're going with this, right?
And so again, we need to learn things about God from this section. We learn things
about our father first that we we see
his kingdom is very expansive.
We learn from this section God's kingdom is expansive and here's what I
mean by that.
See, we cherish that picture where the undignified
father is running down the road to embrace his
younger son as he humbly returned. But
when that we see God's heart for the Lost, we we love
that picture. We embrace it. Yes.
Don't miss this.
Don't miss that. The father also came out and
entreated the older son.
You see that?
see
this older son out here throwing a pity party like
throwing a tantrum. The father could have just left him out there.
Forget you man. Come on.
No, he didn't.
What did he do?
Because he loved his older son. Just as much.
Despite the older son's sin
that looked a little bit different than the younger son sin. It
was still in essence sin slapping the
face of the father. He says, I love you enough. I'm
coming out for you, too.
That's what Jesus is doing here with the Pharisees. He's showing
them the gods kingdom is expansive God's kingdom
includes both religious people and irreligious people.
It means that just like the tax collectors and sinners
had received Jesus Compassionate Care. He's
saying hey Pharisees. It's open for you, too.
If you have eyes and ears to hear and see right you could
get in the party too if you humble yourself.
with a repentant attitude
you're welcome in the
Park which again shows us this love is reaching.
Kingdom is expansive. It's all kinds of people. It's love
is reaching it's going right. He left the house
to go to the younger son who was coming down
the road. He left the house to go to the older son to say.
Hey, come on in.
His love is reaching it's going all kinds of
people all kinds of backgrounds all kinds of sin struggles. Even when
that sin struggle is self-righteousness.
and judgmentalism
He's saying.
repent
Come into the party.
That's the same way in for both sons.
humility repentance
So we learn again about God about his kingdom about his heart. We see
it, but I want to focus in as we head towards
closing today. I want to focus in on what God is teaching us about us in
this section.
Because again, this is the punchline, right? This is the this is
where Jesus was heading the whole time.
And he implies a couple piercing questions that we need all of
us to answer.
First question we would see here is as you
imagine those hearers starting to feel
this question come up for us as well the first
question.
How will we respond to others?
Because in essence what Jesus is doing here is he's saying
to the Pharisees I came to love those Sinners
because you didn't.
Because you aren't.
Here's what I mean. You remember the story of Israel all the
way back from Abraham.
Is that God set apart that Nation to
be vessels of blessing to All
Nations?
To love the lost to to show God off
to those around them and yet what the story shows
us is that they progressively pulled away
from those people.
They progressively jerked away from others to
separate themselves from the nations from the laws.
Instead of fulfilling their identity as a vessel
of Mercy. Listen, we have a similar call today. If
we asynchrony these five says are is ambassadors of
reconciliation. If God has set us apart Christians
set us apart Church to be
his ambassadors. We are not to pull away
and stay in our holy huddles.
We are to live scent to go to
them to reach with his love
that reached us. We can reach with his Mercy as
well.
And so will we spend time with people far from
God?
Will be care for them will we show them the image of
God as we are created to do as vessels of Mercy blessing
to others. Will we do that like Jesus did
or
will we sit back and self-righteous judgment?
Demanding that they get their lives together before coming in.
See the kingdom values Jesus was proclaiming here demand
a shift in our perspective toward
those who are far from God.
Like the older son.
sat back and said
you love that guy.
Because that's the second question.
I think it's a little more even cutting deeply in
our souls not only how we respond to others. How will
we respond to the father?
How will we respond when the father?
asks us
these questions
See, that's the twist in this Parable right? You saw it?
That probably most of us should identify with the older son here.
Yes, we identify with a younger son. Of course we
do and we should that's true. But for most of us,
we think we're doing okay.
We think the way that we serve God is sufficient. We
think that we obey most of God's commands. And so God you
we deserve something from you. We deserve you
to bless us and to give us good things and
and to make our lives easy and we start to think inherently in
that this older brother syndrome that those who live in
blatant sin those people out there. They don't deserve God's
love.
They've gone too far. How could you ever love them?
You should love me.
You should bless me.
Is that you today?
Is that your
Heart attitude and the way you feel at times even ever
say it out loud, but do you feel that?
See God is showing us this.
True nature. It's forgiving is loving heart.
How will we respond to him?
See if you notice.
Jesus intentionally left this Parable open-ended
We don't know how the older brother responded.
Men, praise God if he came in the house.
What the travesty?
If you would have stayed outside.
What that should do for us what it did for the Pharisees as
they hear this.
What it should do for us is it should?
It should cause us to check our hearts allow God
to search our hearts and to dig out
those roots that we might deny or there
the things that we might not see at the at the face
of everything. Do do we have this kind of attitude. Do
we see God's love and compassion as something
unworthy for them, but worthy for me. Do we
have that in us at all?
Because listen God our Father.
Is inviting you into the party.
A party that's full of joy and gladness and
eternal feasting because the Lost
are found because Sinners are saved. Will
you be there?
Whether you're the older son or the younger son in this Parable
the father is coming out of the
house, and he's inviting you in to the party.